the trailer dropped today from the  Kardashian would you think when you saw  that you know everyone has their truth  in their story and so how do you feel  that you're being portrayed in this  hopefully like myself and you know the  real me will shine and hopefully  everyone finds peace in their truth I  feel like you've moved on like this is  like you are not going backwards  well life moves on money doesn't stop  world doesn't stop and hopefully  everyone is just you know going forward  from what's next where do you want to go  what are you gonna do  hopefully the sky's the limit so just  keep going keep working trying new  things getting into acting I have my  activewear line more designing and just  really moving forward and keeping  positive people around me I sense that  this is a real positive Bob that you  have going on is that what it's about  yeah life is short you know tomorrow is  not promised so just always say as  positive as possible  [Music]